[Music]
via motte who is turning young Muslims
into terrorists I'll be discussing that
issue today with ahmed mansour a
berlin-based psychologist and expert on
Islamism Elena's welcome thank you true
dicey deposit man and welcome DW viewers
I'm Thomas fun mr. Mansour you've had
personal experience with this topic
you're Palestinian and grew up in Israel
you turn to Islamism while you were in
school wat xieng gets old other esta mal
my nipples Alicia kriesel I was going
through a personal crisis at the time
and I thought that the Islamists could
help me deal with it that was fed up I
was being bullied at school I was all by
myself can I had no friends aquaduct ab
fuken I was depressed I was worried
about the future zion.t foolish k so it
was great to feel part of an elite group
Hamish the Athenian and this have been
shingi got none doth I know ma I made
contact with the Islamists I started out
with normal Quran lessons and that
turned into lessons in ideology in
ideology that was founded on hatred and
that's why I can talk about Islamism
today because back then I was an
Islamist at opening me at the top haba
peanut did you commit acts of violence
today soo bin ich glaub ich hab field so
far I didn't want to do that because I
had too much to lose the Imams who
taught me told me to study hard work my
way into society and take a proactive
role but they did not advocate violence
Celia voted to happen I had plans for
the future so I wasn't particularly
interested in violence anyway but I did
glorify the question is how should we
define violence about finish for example
if I harass my sisters or limit their
freedom that's a form of violence if I
harass or insult a neighbor because she
doesn't wear a headscarf that's also a
form of violence hopeful take that if
death oh hi now so we have to expand our
definition of violence it's more than
just terrorist attacks mattero
admittance league and forbidden
somebody King demands are our young
Muslim men especially vulnerable to
radical indoctrination radically 0-11 v
Florida Kelly fiancée there are three
levels in the radicalization process
fufu the first involves psychological
factors people who are going through a
personal crisis or they're depressed
have no father figure or they're looking
for social contact tenacity on conducta
the second level is sociological people
who are looking for an identity and you
want to belong to an elite group they're
isolated from society and finally
there's the ideological level ideology
is a key element in some interpretations
of Islam and it can lead to
radicalization as a human tissue young
Muslims who were raised in families that
support these interpretations can become
radicalized for hun hist currency shadi
collision and the Union and vehicle
sexuality plays an important role in a
young person's development regardless of
their religion young people want to find
themselves how do they do that in
traditional Muslim families the design
factor death logically hugs that's a
factor that can lead to radicalization
particularly of sexuality is considered
taboo finished oath will be and young
people are not allowed to experiment or
to understand their own development the
Islamists can use this to their
advantage woodson diva stable valve in
monday if you can control someone's
sexuality you can control them and that
too can lead to radicalization this hub
mystified sexuality is considered taboo
in many conservative Muslim families
people don't talk about it this is
common not just among Islamists but also
among those who follow a conservative
mainstream interpretation of Islam in
steam conservative a slavish then this
white for brightest yep see how did you
experience that phase where you don't
turn out like your parents expected and
deserve Aden other d4 files of oddish
islamist when I was going through my
Islamist face my moral convictions
restricted my ability to experience my
sexuality that not just because my
family was opposed to it but my
religious role models were as well by my
Natalie gooza
when I went to college in Tel Aviv I
began to experience a certain curiosity
I wanted to fight it because I thought
it was morally wrong but those impulses
got the better of me uh berlitz English
am I did a lot of experimenting in Tel
Aviv do if I made some mistakes but I
also discovered some new feelings and
I'm grateful for that alum Alf no llega
fujian taken on da for Bonita donc pas
man canna by eight stars come it's
dangerous to generalize but in many
Muslim families women's rights are
restricted and so is their sexuality def
hottest impose Langley doesn't but that
doesn't mean that these families will
produce potential terrorists watched it
a few Putin's editors a loogie no alpha
doctor from Vienna the generalizations
are dangerous you can't simply label
someone a potential terrorist I prefer
to refer to generation Allah these are
young people who have a certain set of
attitudes and values that can make them
vulnerable to Islamist ideology some
people don't become Islamists overnight
young people can have certain values
that may lead to radicalization but not
always and that's why prevention is so
important to your phone mohsen a bunny
yes I see also visualize we often hear
of people having become suddenly
radicalized but is that possible that's
a thought I'd be lifted German security
officials often speak of turbo
radicalization but there's no such thing
people don't turn into killers overnight
but they do have certain attitudes
values and behavior patterns it's part
of a process both sometimes we can spot
it sometimes we can't so it's vital that
we raise the issue with these people so
that we can determine whether they have
those convictions but a [ __ ] if they do
we have to take proactive measures and
do it quickly by dan will say via their
active additional active at today's
Islamists are able to communicate
effectively with young people so we have
to be faster than they are this
hallucination lrfd some eastern side in
even butta said in your book do you
discuss this generation Allah and the
dangers posed by the Salafists and ultra
conservative branch of Islam what makes
the Salafist so dangerous if any now
that's five thousand foot well we've all
seen what's happened
2015 ishtyle before there were attacks
in Brussels in Paris Berlin roxburgh and
Anton schlag in Berlin vote spoke and
spa in the end when we examine the
background of these young perpetrators
we see that they were active in specific
sound risk groups Salafist issue- the
activa this goes beyond an
interpretation of Islam I need you
loogie it's an ideology that's based on
dehumanizing people maintaining complete
organizational control actively
recruiting new members and in extreme
cases using violence against perceived
enemies mentioned a thought super vague
and developed unto them Zevon inferred
UNS alle Fister some experts say that
Salafist mosques have become meeting
points for potential terrorists devil is
lunch you think that the german
government turned a blind eye to the
situation for too long and what's over
shot at globus nice dish i don't think
so if a Salafist imam actively calls for
violence the authorities will intervene
but there are some legal restrictions
the german constitution guarantees
freedom of religion this right must be
protected this makes it difficult to
shut down a suspect mosque but if an
imam advocates violence the authorities
have to step in there have been
Islamists handing out free currents on
the street in Germany as part of their
recruiting program but they didn't just
hand out quran's they also tried to talk
people into joining islamic state or
other terrorist groups when a religious
subgroup develops a fascist ideology
society in general and the authorities
in particular have to take action we
have to speak out and say this is not
acceptable Yadav and the stone can get
in response you advocate an enlightened
interpretation of Islam Islam do the big
muslim association support that as well
as I do not of course not these groups
are part of the problem not part of the
solution they promote a conservative
interpretation of Islam that can lead to
radicalization that is not helpful
accordingly
wanted to help resolve this situation
they should support reforms above an
defied Islamism effectively all of
society has to get involved Muslims have
to ask themselves how could Islam
produce something so monstrous what sort
of alternatives can we offer to our
young people we have to stand up for
democracy and human rights mention s
dish team we also have to help teachers
identify radical behavior in students
and put a stop to it and then since 08
Kendig and saw a baton via Muslim we
have to do social work in the digital
media sector and crack down on illegal
content means the support democratic
values must play a more active role in
winning young Muslims to our side before
the Islamists can get to them given
before the state slamming into the gap
is insufficient amount of the European
Court of Human Rights recently ruled
that Muslim schoolgirls in Switzerland
have to take swimming lessons together
with boys listen select finished metal
ish yes right Lisa and confident Muslim
girls should receive the same education
as non Muslim girls people who say
otherwise are intolerant and racists and
they're interfering with the future of
these children mention the Muslims the
untouched listen we have to support
those children so that they can live
their lives the way they want to it's
ugly so I'm grateful for the court's
ruling the hotel yet Skookum miss
Champlain get shocked to see you sad to
hear that the major Muslim associations
in Germany don't support your calls for
reform will you be able to change Islam
without their Beckham confine Duncan
Islam suffered an additional minor oh
I'm not the only one who's calling for
reform we have to create a movement and
theologians have to get involved as well
the big Muslim associations do not
represent a majority of Muslims maybe
just twenty-five or thirty percent of
the most Muslims don't belong to
religious organizations dr. some Muslims
will disagree with me but a lot of
people think reforms are a good idea and
they support my efforts loyalty that's
good Finn we have to encourage those
people for benzene
and make it clear to society in general
and the politicians in particular where
we stand as a chef will see they have to
know who is part of the solution and who
is part of the promise that I'd this
book gives commands were via now as we
come to the end of our interview I'd
like you to complete three sentences for
us batons ed to number 1 i'm a muslim i
was born in Israel but I live in Germany
because lion but he's my country I feel
at home here when my family is here
oceania familia hubba decima Palestinian
who has won the moses mendelssohn prize
for promoting tolerance this award was
for me oh it did finish and a growth a
great honor wanna finish that
strengthens my commitment to fighting
hatred Envy vla'ben dismiss best way to
stop the radicalization of young Muslims
is a new political approach Schaben
ahmed mansour thank you my pleasure